if you want to learn how billionaires
like Mark Cuban Jeff Bezos and Carlos
Slim think act and make decisions then
this video is for you I've had
girlfriends where it was like me or your
business and out you know I was like
what was your name again you know get
rich slowly schemes are not big sellers
on infomercials you learn from mistakes
always what's that believe nation it
seven my one word is believe and I
believe in you I believe you have an
amazing gift inside you that I want to
see explode out into the world I started
that how billionaires think series to
try to learn more about billionaires
have had a lot of success at least in
the entrepreneurial world and adapt some
of their mindsets their belief systems
into ourselves to help us become the
best entrepreneur possible so to help
you along your journey today we're gonna
look at how billionaires think success
advice from the top volume seven enjoy
so coming up first
Mark Cuban be willing to make sacrifices
you know I I didn't have as many
personal relationships as I probably
would have liked you know I put personal
relationships aside you know I had
girlfriends where it was like me or your
business and I you know I was like what
was your name again you know
you think I'm kidding
so it probably took things to an extreme
but yeah I gave up on personal
relationships in a big respect because I
really was on a mission and once I once
I realized I was good so when I sold my
first company I bought a lifetime pass
in American Airlines and my goal was
just a party with like a rock star in as
many countries with as many people as I
possibly could then I went back and got
involved in the streaming business and I
remember sitting there and telling you
know we had probably 10 employees and
look the streaming thing I think is
going to be really big and so we really
have to focus and there's going to be
some sacrifices and if you're willing to
make those sacrifices let's go
and if you're not I understand you know
you make your own decisions and I was
willing to make those sacrifices and you
know it all turned out great in the long
run but during that time wasn't always
wasn't always easy and wasn't always
yeah it was tough sometimes up next at
number two is be long-term oriented with
Jeff Bezos I ask everybody to not think
in two to three-year timeframes but to
think in five to seven-year timeframes
to not think about when somebody says to
me congratulate Sam azan on a good
quarter which is a very common thing to
say you meet somebody they're being nice
they looked at your financial results
for the quarter that good quarter I say
thank you but what I'm thinking to
myself is that quarter all that those
quarterly results were actually pretty
much fully baked about three years ago
and so like today I'm working on you
know a quarter that is going to happen
in 2020 not next quarter next quarter
for all practical purposes is done
already and it's probably been done for
a couple of years and so if you start to
think that way it changes how you spend
your time how you plan where you put
your energy and and your ability look
around corners gets better so many
things improve if you can take a long
term by the way it's not
natural for humans so it's a it's a
discipline that you have to build the
kind of you know get rich slowly schemes
are not big sellers on infomercials you
know it's and so that's something that
you have to sort of steel yourself for
discipline and teach over time number
three is learn from your mistakes with
Carlos Slim have you had failures
failures yes what I say to my children
that you need to have failures but try
to make small failures as more mistakes
our orphan business and in life not to
make big mistakes you learn from
mistakes always and from the mistakes of
the others you need to learn knowledge
is more important to learn of other
mistakes that make your mistakes to
learn
number four is have heroes with Mark
Zuckerberg there were probably a lot of
people who can who can run Microsoft
into a reasonable job when I was growing
up Bill Gates was my hero
oh come on yes he's like Darth Vader he
thought he thought Luke Skywalker he's
the bad guy no he is not
Bill Gates ran one of the most mission
driven companies that I can think of
right and you know right now I think
Microsoft
their mission is less focused than it
used to be but when I was thinking about
you know what would I want it to be when
when I grew up you know Microsoft I
thought had it had a great mission put a
computer on every desktop and in every
office right or maybe was every desktop
and every call but
and you know I mean there are companies
that define themselves by a way of doing
things right I mean there's them like
the HP way that I was talking about and
there were companies that define
themselves by making a concrete change
in the world and you know Microsoft did
that and I like I have a huge amount of
respect for him for doing that he pushed
them and it was an incredibly inspiring
company during the time that he was
doing that I think that they're they
still are doing a lot of things but I
think that they've lost some of the
focus and I don't know I mean I think
he's like one of the one of the greatest
visionaries that our that our industry
has ever had
number five is believe in your
philosophy with Jack Ma one of things
that's so fascinating to me is that
Amazon and Jeff Bezos have pursued what
might be described as a very asset heavy
business model they're buying airplanes
they want to own the entire supply chain
from beginning to end
and Alibaba has effectively an asset
like business it is very much in terms
of the retail piece of this the opposite
you don't want to own the warehouses you
don't want to own the logistics
companies how do you think about that is
Jeff Bezos right or are you right and is
there is there going to be a meeting in
the middle I hope both are right and
because the world can never have a one
model if the world has only one correct
model there was too boring right we need
to have all kinds of models and the
people who do the bottom should believe
in the model and I believe what I do
right the difference between Amazon and
us everything is more like an empire
everything they should control
themselves buy and sell and our
philosophy is that we want to be an
ecosystem our philosophy is to empower
others to sell empower others to sit to
service empower making sure the other
people are more powerful than us making
sure with our technology our innovation
our partners I was 10 very small
business sellers they can compete with
Microsoft IBM our philosophy is that we
we think using internet technology we
can make every company become Amazon
next up is number
six care about people with Richard
Branson I think the key the key to I
think being a good business leader is is
your is how good you are with people I
think if you can care it genuinely care
about people not just your fellow
directors but you know the cleaning lady
the switchboard operator
you know everybody throughout the
company you know if you're a good you
know if you know if you praise and don't
criticize you know people people will
flourish and so I think you know it's
really your people skills that will set
you set you apart and and and I don't
think that could be over over emphasized
I think that just you just got to you
know if I'm on a virgin plane I will
make sure that I always have a notebook
in my back back pocket you know make
sure I get out and talk to all the staff
you know if they've got issues you know
make sure I don't just you know hear the
issue will not write it down make sure
those those issues get written down you
know talk to the passengers if they've
got issues make sure those issues get
written down how many at number seven is
cross the jungle with Ray Dalio
firstly can you tell us are you
authenticating
do you have an experience in life of
being successful I don't think that
success is like a lot of people believe
it is and for any really successful
person I think that everybody's always
struggling and what happens is you know
you just struggle at a higher level it's
like learning how to ski or play some
sport and you're just kind of doing this
higher thing but it doesn't feel like
that it just feels like I'm struggling
and I think it's and and it's a good
feeling I the way I think of it is I've
always thought that it's like in order
to be successful in life you have to
cross a jungle or you can stay on the
other side of the jungle and not cross
the jungle but if you choose to cross
the jungle the jungle has all sorts of
things that can do your harm and bite
you and everything along those lines and
so the West best way to do that is to go
into that with people who can see things
differently and watch themselves and
struggle to make it to the other side
and then what I've discovered along the
way is that it's always a struggle and I
enjoy being in the jungle I don't want
to get to the other side I don't want to
get out so that's what it feels like to
me next up at number eight is be curious
with Sam Zell an entrepreneur is someone
who thinks differently someone who
recognizes and understands opportunity
but combines that recognition of
opportunity with solutions and then in
the end it's all about curiosity I've
never met an entrepreneur who was
successful who wasn't extraordinarily
curious number nine is don't rely on
luck with Jack Dorsey I think that's one
of the strongest things you can
cultivate as an entrepreneur is to not
rely on luck but cultivating and the
ability to recognize fortunate
situations when they're occurring mm-hmm
odyo was a very fortunate situation I
could have taken that idea not told it
to have not told it to be is not not
told it to know and and all my other
co-workers at OU do and tried to start
my own company with with that idea but
the fortunate situation was I was
working with some really amazing people
and we had a great team so of course you
know it makes sense to start there the
fortunate situation for square was that
in 2008 at the end of 2008 the entire
market was crashing down like all of
these abstractions we built upon
abstraction upon abstraction upon
abstraction in the financial world which
no single human understood we're now
falling apart and suddenly we're getting
back to basics back to fundamentals
management teams were being asked to
leave banks were failing you know people
were
we're clarifying around like we need to
start getting innovative if we need to
start treating our customers so poorly
we need to start in set we need to stop
you know encouraging bad behavior to
reap fees like we need to really turn
this whole thing around and anytime
there's a recession or a depression
that's a great time to innovate start a
company start a project you know do
anything so you know we recognize we
recognize that time and at the same time
my co-founder Jim we you know we
contacted me he I've known him since I
was 15 years old he was my boss when I
was 15 years old
and he's like Jack I want to talk to you
I want to I want to build an electronic
car company like that's interesting and
he was thinking about it because the car
industry was failing as well and like he
was like why don't we just give these
car companies to well seasoned
entrepreneurs like why don't we give
Ford to Steve Jobs and like you know
that would be amazing
yeah it would be amazing and like you
know GM to Ellison are like what not
he's like and also I want to start an
electronic car company I'm like that's
ambitious but in that moment we decided
not to start an electronic car company
but we wanted to do something together
mm-hm and we kept having these weekly
conversations about what that thing was
and I was researching a lot with finance
and healthcare because I was looking at
you know doing something in those spaces
and and Jim called me one day one of us
scheduled me to meetings and he said I
just lost a glass sale he's an artist he
he sells class and I lost the sale
because I couldn't accept a credit card
and here he was talking on his iPhone
his general-purpose computer and I was
talking about my iPhone I'm like we
could go Hertz computer sitting in the
palm of your hand but no way to accept
credit he couldn't accept $2,000 from
from someone who wanted to pay him right
like why is that so we decided that we
wanted to answer that question and we
did a bunch of research and I started
writing some server code and we hired a
guy to write some iPhone code and Jim
built some hardware and in a month we
had a little way it was actually quite a
big device that plugged into the audio
jack of your iPhone
and could swipe the cart take a payment
it would go through the merchant process
and then generate a receipt with a map
on it and I went around I showed it to a
bunch of investors and they were all
amazed that it could even work so we
decided to really focus on it and make
it a negative company and and it really
just comes out of like recognizing that
fortunate situation and recognizing the
people around you that that could help
and and just owning it and number 10
solve problems with Travis kalanick my I
like to say my management style as
problem solver in chief and so what I do
in a given day is I have a set of
problems that need to be solved and I
started the most important and work my
way down and for the problems I don't
have time for somebody else gets to
solve them now if somebody's already
solving another problem of solving a
problem I need to get involved if the
problems getting solved but you know
people go wow so your days just full of
problems I'm like yeah I've got a lot of
problems but but it's sort of like how a
math professor thinks of problems right
is that think of a great math professor
who has no math problems to solve
he's a very sad math professor and so
that's very much how I look at it
solving problems is a you know every
problem is an opportunity for innovating
and being creative and finding something
new and that's what I love to do and I
do it every day thank you guys so much
for watching
I'd have to say number five believe in
your philosophy with Jack Ma is my
personal favorite I love to know from
you guys was number five year favorite
it was there something else that had a
bigger impact more immediate impact on
you I'd love to know leave it down in
the comments below I also want to give a
quick shout out to Deborah Jyoti
Banerjee thank you so much for picking
up a copy of my book your one word and
posted it to your social media accounts
I really really appreciate the support
and I'm so glad you enjoyed my book so
thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one where it is much love I'll see you
soon
raise your
standard Apple at the core its core
value is that we believe that people
need passion and people not one drop of
myself work depends on Europe it's
suppose to mean I don't ever give up I'd
have to be dead or absolutely in faster
hey believe nation if you want to see my
all-time favorite top ten Rose a success
I have a very special secret video for
you these are the individual clips that
I have personally learned the most from
and applied to my life and my business
check the link in the description for
details